i've seen you posting all over instagram
ice vending machines and when i first
saw this i was like man i used to think
that the two scams in the world were
selling water and then selling air and
those two things would possibly not ever
become a real business and then the big
brain somewhere came up with selling
frozen water
in a bag is in these ice vending
machines so explain what's going on here
and how these businesses work
yeah it's wild well we're actually doing
a deal right now with one of the
companies it's called the ice house of
america and of course you could guess
who owns them which is private equity
firms because they always know where the
zeros are um but essentially what this
is is i was driving around austin texas
and we have this one main street i'm
sure you guys have seen it too but like
gas station convenience store whatever
and right next to it was this little
house and in the house there was a line
this day of people waiting to get a bag
of ice that slides out the chute and
they put it in their ice chest and off
they go and i was like wait a second no
employees
nobody around like no um you know hard
assets besides this tiny little thing
what i imagine was a couple hundred
dollar lease what is this business and
is it profitable and so i went down my
little rabbit hole and realized there's
this whole industry called ice vending
and there are thousands of these all
over the country and they're kind of
these little
passive-ish businesses similar to a car
wash or a laundromat or essentially you
set up the infrastructure and then
people pay you for common services and
what's wild is the margins on these
things i mean a bag of
of
ice in austin texas is pre-inflation so
who knows now by the numbers are
different but let's call it you know um
75 cents typically
now the price is closer to 1.50.75
um and uh and you get your bag costs you
anywhere from 15 to 25 cents and so you
make the margin or the difference
between the two and i love these little
boring business nobody thinks about
super easy to run high margin low people
businesses so pretty much all you have
to do is you have to hook up the
water and then it's freezing it inside
of the machine and making the ice and
really the only other material uh is
electricity and then the uh bags
themselves and like if you have those
three things then you're in business
with one of these machines that's
exactly right you need the land you need
the machine you need some bags that are
inside of it and you need a water hookup
and electricity hookup and then you want
to be like on a street corner that has
about 10 000 cars a day that's pretty
easy to check any realtor i'll be able
to tell you what the car count is
typically um so you need some foot
traffic or to be located by like a
school or lots of construction sites or
um a lake national parks um but those
that's kind of all you need for this
sort of business and then it's
relatively cheap to start anywhere from
what's called 25 to 150k for the machine
and then like i said you could lease the
land but the machines you get um
equipment loans on so those start at a
couple hundred bucks a month um for you
to kind of get rolling and the break
even looks like you start breaking even
well you start making money month one if
you do your due diligence right
obviously and pick the right location
and then it looks like the break even on
these things is anywhere from three to
six years which is really low for real
estate so when you think about this uh
atms the business that we've spent a lot
of time looking at we actually have a
bitcoin atm sitting in here right now uh
when we think about those they're paying
the gas station or or location to put it
in their store and that's why the store
allows them to put it there uh and then
they just are taking their fee are these
ice vending machines are they paying to
place their uh uh unit or are they uh
just paying some sort of like uh lease
or like how does this work exactly to
the way that they get it uh in the
location
usually a lease so very cheap because
you only need one segment of the parking
lot let's call it like a parking space
and a half so that people can kind of
turn around
um so they're leasing and the leases are
pretty cheap like i said i mean it
depends on the city so wide variability
but let's call it 200 bucks to 500 bucks
a month um you could have a lease on
something like that i probably go on the
lower end there but you're exactly right
now the reason i like ice mending i've
done a decent amount of of looking at
atm machines you guys are the crypto
king so i'm not going to mess with you
there but um the atm machine model i
don't love because the margins are
actually so tiny and you know cash is
increasingly not as utilized so um
bitcoin i think is is interesting um but
any of the people that have reached out
to us we own some laundromats they've
reached out to put bitcoin atms in the
laundromats um and they pay us a flat
fee because my understanding is uh you
can't take a cut on bitcoin transactions
without some sort of licensing so yeah
that's the difference between the two
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time